what we are seeing for the time being is
egoism instead of common European sense
the 28 member states a 507 million
inhabitants if it is tribute five
hundred thousand refugees that meinst
507 million it is not a problem if you
concentrate all the refugees of to some
of the member states it is a problem if
we would create an imagined your
imagination or an impression that just
come because we are ready to accept
everybody that would be a moral failure
because this is not the case so the
moral human thing is to make clear
please don't come why you have to go
from Turkey to euro turkey is a safe
country stay there don't criticize
Hungary for doing what is the capacity
to be done and instead of criticizing us
just let us hungry do the job as it is
written in the European regulation
chicken treatise on the threat is
absolutely clear and if we don't solve
the problem then the threat for the free
movement will increase but I belong to
those who are not prepared to reduce a
fundamental right guarantee to European
citizens and to put it in doubt because
we have an influx of refugees to the
European Union